hello folks
welcome to rational science directly
from frankfurt germany
and the only site on the internet that
does
physics
right
everybody else does mathematics which is
the movement of concepts
and we're going to be talking a little
bit about that today tonight over here
uh but before i've got a couple of
announcements
the first one's uh not really an
announcement it's uh more like a
clarification
and it comes at the heels of a comment
someone made so let me put that up there
okay this is what the foul said he said
i have this thing when the owner of a
channel never bothers to reply to any
comment it's a huge lack of respect
and another fellow answers him and says
why did you delete all your comments
over a two-day period of debate
and the fellow answers he says i deleted
because i had the intention of leaving
this channel for good
until i saw this
other guy's comment which i replied to
and since nothing i can say seems to
make a difference in your thinking well
why leave all that debate there for
nothing
well i think uh
that's what is a
lack of respect deleting comments
uh people who do not want to stand by
their arguments i guess uh they feel
ashamed of them i have no idea why they
would not leave a comment behind
and that's the main reason i don't
answer questions directly in my site
okay
and it is because you know when i
started a few
what is it like 10 years ago a little
over 10 years
uh 15 years
um
i engaged in a lot of discussions i mean
my first
20 videos
uh
if you look at them today i still have
the comments there i just uh wiped out
the comment in other words the comments
are there but i just don't let people
see those comments don't let people add
comments
and if you see those comments i'm
probably the guy that's got the most
comments on the internet you know for
for such a small site you know i've got
tons of comments and i'm not talking
about one-liners i'm talking about full
paragraphs where people really carry it
on discussions
and what a lot of people would do after
they engage
you know we have new theory here
obviously there's going to be a lot of
dissent and we expect that
but what a lot of these people did was
they deleted their comments or a lot of
them just used fake names and they
deleted the names
and you ended up having answering you
know if you look at the the series of
comments today you're answering to
people who are not there anymore and all
that you can see is your own comments
and so you know i think that's a lousy
thing to do and so because of that i
don't answer any more
questions on youtube
what i do is i have a session here at
the end of each video in which i answer
questions that people ask throughout the
week so i do answer questions and it
gives me more time to look at the
questions you know and some of them i
have to research you know and so i can
give them a proper answer but you know
i'm not going to answer to someone
especially like this fellow who uh the
next thing he does is delete his
comments or run away
you know that is you know i think such
people should be banned from the
internet that's my position on that and
so no i'm not gonna answer directly in
yahoo unless on in youtube i mean unless
you know uh there is a question of
policy okay and again like this one this
is a question of policy of how i handle
these things so no i don't skirt
questions
and i don't care if you come here and
cuss my mother i really don't care i'm
not going to delete your comment i'm not
going to mess with your comment you know
sometimes youtube deletes comments
because they don't like
uh
urls being put in there i have no idea
what their policy is but i never touch a
comment okay so you don't have to worry
about that from me
uh if i see and again you can say
whatever you want if i see something in
there that i believe it needs addressing
then i'll bring it up and i'll
you know discuss it online and then once
a month we have live shows you know
where you can ask questions directly
people have a million questions i can't
address them all please understand that
i try to look through there and see if
there's something that you know that's
interesting and that's what i'll
discuss
okay
uh so the announcements uh you know uh
one is that i'm gonna be on the road for
the next couple weeks
and so the next uh um
lecture will probably be next sunday
okay and i'm gonna do my best to be here
on sunday
and um
on this channel i mean not here in
frankfort i'll probably be somewhere
else
uh the other one is that ons my son he
is coming at the end of the month
he's uh was sent on a secret mission
a damsel in distress that he
rescued i guess
was about to rescue
and uh so i'm uh happy to get him back
in at the beginning of june probably
and then for those of you who asked
about the lawsuit
yeah we're in court now and uh we're
suing these mathematical biophysicists
okay
and um
uh yeah we're in court we're
probably gonna
be there for a while
and
uh the issue there is that these people
these uh uh biophysicists they copied uh
not only the rope model
and started to make money with it but
they also copied the definitions
something we're going to talk about
today
and you know those definitions are
copyrighted in the uh why god doesn't
exist
first book i wrote on the subject
and uh
you know if you want to follow up on the
uh
on the lawsuit itself on the case i
posted a thread on the rational
scientific method in in facebook
so you can find it there okay
and so yeah those interested can uh in
the subject can
you know
go to that rational scientific method
and they'll find out more about it
okay
so what is it that you know that i'm
defending in that in that lawsuit and
also here because you know i i talk
about this quite often and which is also
the subject of today
in great measure and these are the words
what i
put in that book were the foundations of
physics you cannot do physics unless you
define these words at least these words
there's some more but these i guess are
the main ones
and so yes you need to define these
words in order to give a physical
interpretation
to
a phenomenon okay
and
the main one is that word there the word
object
and uh like i say the definition of the
word object destroys all religions once
you define the word object all religions
have to go
all religions are based on spirits on
concepts and we can't use those to uh
give a physical interpretation to any
phenomenon
and so that's the key issue okay
um
here um here we have um
a second here
here's the pictorial representation of
those words okay
you have the
object which is that which has shape
there you have a captain the dog does
have shape
distance separation between objects
location is the set of distances from
one object to all the rest
and that also plays into the word exist
because in order for you to exist you
have to have location you have to be an
object and you have to have location
meaning you have to have a set of
distances with all objects in the
universe if god wants to exist all he's
got to do is meet the definition of the
word exist and then he exists by
definition period okay it's got nothing
to do with belief or anything else
um emotion
it's two or more locations of one object
okay so if you take two or more steps
you've uh you have essentially
motion
and time we don't use the word time in
science but we define it for the
mathematicians so they know what they've
been talking about these last 2 500
years
and times is a comparison of two motions
and it requires memory
what is space well space is the opposite
of an object okay a thing is the
opposite of nothing
and space is that which doesn't have
shape it's exactly the opposite of an
object
so we have these definitions and once
you have those definitions you are able
to
communicate
your theory to another human being in a
rational manner so they can follow
you know your arguments your theory okay
your explanation
okay uh what are the forbidden words
words that we cannot use in physics
these are used in
mathematics as we call it a religion
that attempts to
merge
physics with mathematics an impossible
task it's impossible you can math has
nothing to do with physics physics has
nothing to do with math but these people
are called mathematical physicists
and we call them math magicians because
they end up doing everything by magic
what is magic black magic the movement
of concepts it's okay to move you know
spirits because you're gonna leave or a
ghost because i mean if you painted like
casper the friendly ghost at least you
can see something you say well it's this
uh flying uh you know bed sheet okay
with two eyes and a nose and a mouth so
we can all deal with the bed sheets
because we say okay that's the spirit
okay fines got super powers goes through
walls etc no problem there
but when you start moving concepts
around whoo that's scary i mean
you need a lot of beers in order to do
that you know when you start moving
intelligence around and love and you
know energy and
you know fields
then you know you're in trouble and so
some of these words uh are not allowed
in physics okay and they're widely used
in mathematics and people learned on my
road in high school you know in uh
at the monasteries okay as we say okay
and here they are these are some of the
ones that are forbidden okay it's uh
words like energy field time
wave and mass plasma uh you have the
people at the uh electric universe
they're fanatics of the word plasma a
lot of them also
adhere to the ether okay
charge you know what is charge force
they use force as a physical object they
said the force may the force go with you
orbital they treat it as a physical
object infinity they think that infinity
is something so they say oh i went to
infinity like you know over there
the vortex another famous words of
of the electric universe a lot of them
like the word vortex they think it's uh
this tornado is a thing
okay
point line and obviously we do not use
numbers in science not at all not one
bit anyone doing math has nothing to do
with science or with physics we have no
use for numbers okay
and so we typically call them idiots an
idiot is an individual with very very
big ideas it comes from the middle
klingon meaning big idea okay like idiot
okay it's not just a little idea it's an
idiot
okay so we call them idiots
uh yeah none of those words are allowed
in science none of those words are
allowed in physics and they're not
allowed because first of all they're
quantitative
meaning they're going to describe
and we have no use for description
science is interested in explanations
that's where you have to break your
brain and no uh explanations are not uh
made of descriptions okay we have a
different
issue with explanation i've discussed it
in the past and there's also a video out
there so you can look it up
anyways um
the other thing that we don't
use are some of the
um
activities that they do in mathematics a
lot of people think that these
activities are pertinent to physics
they're not okay
and here they are these are the
forbidden activities and processes
we don't count we have no use for
counting okay
number you know
no use for that at all we do not do
predictions that's astrology palm
reading and who knows what but certainly
not part of science we have no use for
predictions
we do not observe we do not gawk
okay you can observe all day and not
understand anything so observation is
not part of science or of physics and we
always remove the witness we do it mafia
style we kill the witness and that's
part of the problem with observe that a
lot of people say i observed in the lab
well you know maybe you just inferred
thinking that you observed
and uh we don't measure anything we have
no use for measurement we have no use
for experiments okay you can do all the
experiments you want at home in your own
basement okay
and when you come to conference we want
you to explain
what you understood what you got out of
it but to do an experiment we we don't
allow you to do experiments at the
conference okay like uh michael faraday
used to do experiments in front of
people with magnets and electricity and
so on that's not science that's uh
voodoo
that's magic
magician we do not falsify
it's it's uh really illegal to falsify
things as far as i know you know so we
do not falsify anything they say that in
mathematics that they falsify theories
we have no idea what that is especially
when falsified means that it's your
opinion
and opinions belong to religion so
whenever you falsify or
or truthify you convert something prove
and turn something into truth uh none of
that has anything to do with science
that's got to do with your beliefs and
with religion
uh because we don't experiment we don't
test anything we don't verify anything
you know we don't verify you can verify
all of what you want at home in your own
dark basement but in science we do not
verify anything because that has to do
again with belief
we do not prove we do not use use has to
do with technology okay and science is
different with technology than
technology a lot of people confuse the
the you the notions
of technology with science they think
it's the same in fact you'll find many
of the headings like in youtube and so
on they see science and technology and
so a lot of people uh you know confuse
these
authorized we have no authorities in uh
in science in physics no one is an
authority so if you got your phd and you
say well i got authority because you
know i studied all this 10 years and now
i got my phd it's worthless sorry it has
no value you know you could have studied
divinity studies where all we know
works if it works or not that's like use
you know that's got to do with
technology we don't care if it works or
not we want to make sure that we
understand the theory
and that we can crunch it and you know
figure out whether each individual has
to figure out whether they like the
theory or not
and we do not re do repeatable
experiments again because you know it's
nonsense again you can repeat all you
want the experiment
you know throw the pencil as many times
as you want until you figure out that it
always falls to the floor no problem
there when you come to the conference we
need for you to explain why what causes
that pencil to fall to the floor
we do not describe we explain and we do
not vote for theories okay
there is no voting there's no uh
democracy in science okay you can
believe whatever you want okay voting
again is an opinion so you vote you
raise your hands i vote for that theory
great
you know the other guy votes for another
theory
so
what have we learned you know so we
don't care about any of that in science
we need to understand the theory that's
where science stops and religion begins
okay religion begins when you start
giving opinions of what's uh true or
false what's correct and incorrect
that's when we get into religion and as
and people emphasize a lot of that say
oh i need evidence i need proof
you're in the wrong place science
doesn't offer evidence or proof science
offers theory explanations of mechanisms
so that you understand it then you reach
your own conclusion you know in private
that's your problem and that's the way
it works
so how did we end up with all this uh
these
words of mathematics
well for that we have to
even though you may not believe me we
have to go to the bible you know and the
bible you know was uh given to a man by
god okay here he is this is when it
happened okay god gave the bible to man
and in the bible you're gonna find a um
you're gonna find a little story and
it's the story
of uh babel you know the tower of babel
uh and that's where babbling comes from
i think
what happened was that
god
in his wise wisdom he didn't want man to
you know
reach his
heaven
while he was alive you know while he
after death you know maybe your soul
goes to heaven but when you're alive we
don't want you reaching to the heavens
maybe they didn't maybe god didn't want
anyone to see him in his knickers i
don't know you know and so the the issue
is that apparently god has something
against people building buildings to
high levels
and so here you see a little bit of that
story okay uh i'll set it in motion here
and you see how the tower this tower is
called the tower of babel is uh growing
and it grows all the way to you know to
uh to the sky
and so god didn't like that so what god
did was he started to confuse
people you know he he started to create
languages so they would not be able to
oh sorry
so they would not be able to uh
let me put myself back in here give me a
second here
so they would not be able to
talk to each other
and so
that's how languages were created
according to the bible i was given by
god i mean you know you got to believe
that right it's a fact
and so we have all these languages today
and but what a lot of people don't know
is that it was the devil
that's not in the bible by the way
so don't look it up uh the devil is the
one who created the definitions that he
gave to the mathematicians okay
the devil was a mean critter and he said
hey sly guy right and he went in there
and he started making all these
definitions putting them in dictionaries
okay
and so what happened was people started
reading these dictionaries you know and
they walked around they memorized a lot
of the words that were in the
dictionaries
and they created this language that
nobody could understand because the guy
who
put him in there who put those
definitions in there was the devil okay
and so today what we have is uh all this
language created by the mathematicians
who created all this language that
nobody understands and here you see
this is where it all ended up with you
know a lot of people get bored with all
the language that the mathematicians use
and they just go out and get sick of all
this stuff
they're really you know uh
upset that the mathematicians use this
language that nobody understands and
what they do actually is uh you know use
all these fancy words
and
we're we're taught a lot of those by
rote in high school you know like field
and mass and so on
and a lot of people just drop out of the
class say okay thank god i'm over
physics mathematical physics and i'll
never see it again and so later on in
life all they do is they just listen to
these guys they don't understand
anything what they're saying because
they're talking about fields and energy
and mass and all this stuff and they say
well i don't understand any of that but
you look like you're intelligent that
you know what you're talking about you
got all those equations that nobody
understands so you must be right
and so these people can tell them you
know that time is warped
or that they ship the field
or that they transferred energy and
people say okay i think i understand you
you know
and that's
that's all the devil
so god was the fellow who created
you know the uh
the the bible and he said i want
everybody to read it but nobody read it
even to this day nobody reads it
everybody checks the dictionary because
whenever they don't know something they
say well go to the dictionary where do
they go they go to the
ordinary dictionary or to the ordinary
encyclopedia which essentially parrots
the ordinary dictionary and when they're
there it's the devil that takes over
he's the guy who put the words in there
he's the guy who's in charge of the
dictionaries a lot of people didn't know
that okay and so here it is
okay god is the author of the bible
which no one reads anyway right
and the devil is the creator of the
definitions placed in dictionaries
that's how it all ended up okay
so i just wanted you to know the real
story behind this okay
um
just so you know why we have all these
all this language see god separated the
languages but within one language you
would have people who you know
understood that language so that's when
the devil came in put all these fancy
words in there very sly devious words
that you know people use to communicate
thinking they're communicating when
they're not okay
and of course one of those words is the
word exist
okay that we're gonna be dealing with
today
and we're gonna start with this fellow
and he essentially shows that yeah the
devil put this word in the dictionary
okay and didn't define it people think
they have a definition they don't and
this is it you see it here uh an example
again yeah
referring to me he says he uses the
definition of atheist which is
proclaimed by theists and by atheists
themselves
not by atheists themselves
okay and he says atheism is
an absence of belief in the evidence of
deities okay
but then he says i don't believe
is different from i believe
is it
and another
i think he he had the right answer okay
and that's the answer the correct answer
as far as i'm concerned okay you believe
that no god exists but uh become uh
scientifically hypocritical by calling
it disbelief
absolutely
is this belief a form of belief or not
i think he hit it right on the no this
is exactly the thought that i had when i
saw that
and i read this follow his comment i
said i'm going to put that one up there
okay so here it is this is my uh
five cents worth on this okay
and that's the absence of belief is or
equal to disbelief it's the same thing
as belief it's just a different type of
belief
not belief does not make it an antonym
and not believe it's just another belief
okay and
non-belief is just an opinion again and
that's religion religion the definition
of religion is opinion belief okay
that's what it is it's not god it's not
jesus christ or muhammad it's opinion
and it's belief
and belief plays no role in science so
whenever an atheist says i don't believe
it is different from i believe well all
he's showing is that he's just a
religious fanatic that's all he's
showing
and in science we say something
different we say let us assume
that god exists god can only be an
assumption
it's in mathematics where a hypothesis
is not an assumption in
mathematics a hypothesis is a theory
and uh and again mathematics deals with
fact of truth and proof and belief
okay and then and it turns out that
existence has absolutely nothing to do
with belief or with this belief
non-belief any of those skepticism
science uh i mean
say
mathematical physics
believes that this is this is their
rationale you know and this is what this
is what they believe in
okay
and so yeah we we try to separate
mathematics from science
and
the problem is that in mathematics they
harp on belief
they they call those proofs
uh truths
and uh you know evidence all that has to
do with belief none of that has anything
at all to do with science or especially
with physics okay
okay so uh
fellow says
i think yeah
uh i think it's the same though he
continues that uh that's
meaning god right that's not a theory
correct theory and science has to be
testable and falsifiable
a theory has to be testable and
falsifiable no not in science if
anything in religion because falsifiable
means you're going to approve you're
going to try to convince someone to
change his mind you're working on the
belief side of the equation you can say
and that belongs strictly to religion
has nothing to do with science in
science we don't believe in science we
explain so that someone understands and
that's objectively once you understood
we part companies one goes to his church
the other guy did his church and they
believe whatever they want to believe
they can do research they can do
experiments they can do whatever they
want in their dark basements
when they come together again explain i
i want your explanation what caused
the spoon to fall to the floor that's
what i need to find out you need to
explain and you say well i did a million
experiments i did repeatability and and
i measured and i got all this equation
yeah so far you haven't explained
anything
so no we don't care about falsification
because
uh one guy falsifies the other guy's god
that's all we're doing with
falsification i don't like your god so i
falsified him he's not truth to me he's
he's fake and the other guy says exactly
the same thing in fact you could be
talking to a mirror for all you know
okay so he said god is a theory it's a
hypothesis
but he says a hypothesis but the
question is whether this fellow
understands what a hypothesis is because
the mathematicians everybody out there
considers a hypothesis a theory it's a
theory that's in its emphasis so infancy
so so to speak
so
that's a theory a theory nonetheless
that's not what a hypothesis is
hypothesis is an assumption okay and
that's got nothing to do with theory
uh assumptions include the objects that
you're going to use in your theory the
definitions hopefully not from the devil
okay from the ordinary dictionary or
from the encyclopedias out there
especially those scientific ones which
essentially copy everything from the
ordinary dictionary especially the key
words that i mentioned earlier
and uh and yes uh what you need to do is
define and then the next thing you do
part of the hypothesis is you make a
statement of the facts
nobody knows the facts only mother
nature father universe god the devil
those guys know it but they have it in
their file cabinets but we have no
access to the file cabinet all we can do
is make a statement of the facts what we
think happened
you know someone might say well i was at
the crime scene i saw how this guy
killed that woman
and everybody who came later on we don't
know what happened
we have to rely on his word
he said it's a fact
i was here i saw it
yeah
i don't believe you
you're lying
period you know i mean it's just his
opinion we can't reproduce the fact
again
even if you filmed it
you know say that was staged
like a lot of this these moonies say
everything's staged
so you know uh facts are
just beliefs that's all they are so we
do not have facts in science where we
have these statements of the facts
we make an assumption that this is what
happened and on that assumption of that
process we build our theory and we say
this is what caused it to happen
this is this is the physical
interpretation of what happened for the
purposes of physics right
so he says don't get confused like many
do with what's called a theory in
everyday language and what's a theory
regarding to science don't play
semantics yeah i think this fellow is
playing semantics because he doesn't
understand what a theory is or what a
hypothesis is okay
that's what we need to clarify
okay but getting back to the word belief
here we have two gentlemen they
did their best they used their their
maximum brain power uh to come up with
a definition for the word exist
and they never could
why because they um they use the c touch
criteria
and when you see touch for either
what a thing is what an object is
and for the word exist
you're going to be wrong every time you
won't be able to use it consistently
meaning
any any
definition of those two words that
depends on c and touch is
by definition irrational and we're going
to get the definition of definitions
right
but the key issue here is the following
here we have it
we have these two gentlemen one is uh
david hume
and he says the following these this is
in the 18th century okay the idea of
existence then is very is the very same
with the idea of what we conceive to be
existent okay
that idea when conjoined with the idea
of any object makes no addition to it
so
uh hume was not able to tell the
difference between an object
and its existence
so he thought the word object in
existence in essence
were synonyms
he couldn't tell the difference and a
few years later we have kant a german
guy and he came up with the same notion
he says
by whatever and however many predicates
i may think a thing even in uh
completely determining it
nothing really is added to it if i add
that the thing exists
so these two gentlemen they broke their
heads and they called themselves
philosophers
and they were
none of the kind they were just
amateurs uh not even philosophers they
they they didn't do philosophy
philosophy is something else so all
these people like kant and hume you know
they
uh
they they would be kicked out of
philosophy out of genuine philosophy now
they had no idea and the fact that they
dealt with the word exist also shows
that they're not philosophers because
exist belongs the word exists belongs
exclusively to physics physics is the
science of existence physics deals with
what exists physics tries to determine
what exists out there especially in our
invisible world of mother nature and
father universe right we're trying to
figure out what exists out there what is
there
and that's causing all these phenomena
you know such as the spoon falling to
the bar
if you're gonna
uh try to explain that
you gotta figure out what invisible
things are out there first before you
can give an explanation
okay it's no use saying well i measured
this the speed of the uh
uh fall of the uh of the spoon
and i measured how much mass the
uh spoon has and blah blah blah you go
with all this stuff and it fell with so
much energy and this was the field that
was out there you can go with all those
numbers
and it's absolutely useless you need to
tell me what physical entity came in
contact with a spoon
and if you say well i can't see or touch
anything well maybe you're using the
wrong definition for what an object is
and what exists means okay so that's
where we have to start because if an
object is not that which you can see or
touch
if exist has nothing to do with c or
touch
okay
then maybe what's there
is an object
and
again it has nothing to do with being
able to see it or touch
you can't see the air for sure so uh why
would uh in anything made out of atoms
hopefully is a thing okay
so air is a thing whether you like it or
not so we call it an object
and that sounds terrible in the areas of
many people because they're
bringing these notions from ordinary
speech of what an object is in ordinary
speech in our everyday
uh
living you know we touch things we see
things and we say okay an object like a
table is what i can see and touch
and no you can't use that definition in
science you can't use it in physics
because you know i can imagine a table
and that table you cannot see or touch
and certainly you cannot touch the table
that's on the other side of the universe
which is a table anyways it's the one
klingon is sitting on you can't see or
touch it so does that mean that's not an
object
does the word table
refer to an object does the word chair
always refer to an algae
so we have to divide every word in the
dictionary between objects and concepts
objects those which have shape
concepts now that's a little trickier
and that's uh i showed at the beginning
here real briefly but it's a word that
invokes two objects you need to define
the word object first before you define
the word concept okay
okay and uh
so as a consequence these are the
the definitions we have of this uh word
exist today because people like
human can't you know they they were the
ones who
addressed it okay they did the best they
could okay they did a lousy job but they
did the best they could right and this
is what we have today if you look it up
you know you find these
circular arguments or secure circular
definitions
object c touch you know that's the
notion people have existence is also c
touch that which you can see in touch so
today we have no difference though
between object and existence you get the
common man out there the layman and he's
gonna say yeah an object is that which i
can see and touch that's probably what
you're gonna say others say it's a
collection of matter and they don't
realize that a collection of whatever
first is a concept
but
it's not an object collection of
something you know
but if you have a collection of
matter then your matter is already a
collection of objects that's what matter
is so
all you're doing having a circular
definition but then you have you know
exist again does it exist well there are
objects that don't exist and they're
objects and that's what people have
trouble with you know you need location
for it to exist that's the difference
between object and exist anyways here
you see the definition you'll find out
there you can look them up yourself
existence the fact or state of having
objective reality
wikipedia says existence the ability of
an entity to what
interact touch see touch you know with
reality okay what is reality you look it
up exist what is sexuality exist
existence the state of or fact of
existing that's what you find in a
dictionary
and
then you also find exist to have actual
being and you look at being and it's the
fact of existing
so we've learned a lot there you know a
bunch of synonyms so yeah this was this
was done by the devil
keep that in mind okay so double working
is putting his tail in here in the
dictionary so whenever you look for a
word a definition for of a word
never never go to the dictionary not if
you're doing science if you're going to
do for ordinary talk that's fine
but if you're doing science if you're
doing physics
there's only one way and that's
go back to your dark basement you know
close all the doors shut out the lights
get two beers and think you got to break
your brains
and think what is the the scientific
definition how can i use this word
consistently
and once you do that you have a set of
powerful words
that allow you to trash anyone
especially mathematicians okay
okay so what do we have today as a
result that nobody has defined a word
exist well we have the
the three stooges we have the
atheists the deists and the agnostics
and all these people talk about the
belief in existence okay here you have
him okay
uh moe says i believe in existence larry
says i don't believe in existence oh
and curly says i don't know whether to
believe in existence or not
those are the three stooges of religion
okay and um how do we do it in science
well we do it a little differently here
it is okay
we say let us assume so and so
exists okay
so if you're going to talk about god you
say let us assume god exists
then you can use that
assumption that hypothesis
for anything you want okay and what do
you mean when you say let us assume that
god exists you are saying that god has
location okay
what does that mean that means that god
is first an object he's got to be an
object and i'll say he maybe it's a she
we can call it an end we'll just use god
the word god god has to be an object
if god is a concept like love or
intelligence
concepts cannot be said to exist because
exist belongs exclusively to physics
physics deals with objects not with
concepts treated as objects you know you
can't say god is love and then say god
move the over the face of the waters or
you know that kind of thing or you know
god is a field and it vibrates you know
we don't accept that kind of thing now
you can't sneak it in there it's got to
be an object a genuine object it's got
to have shape standalone shape it's got
to be a standalone object okay
and
once you have that yeah no problem once
you have an object you can say it exists
or let us assume it exists let us assume
this star over there in the universe
exists okay you can start like that no
problem at all and then you tell your
theory okay
what are you going to tell us about the
star what explanation are you giving
going to give us okay
okay so what is the scientific
definition of the word exist well here
we have it exist physical presence
that's the correct definition that's a
scientific not correct because you may
not agree but we don't care if you agree
the only way to challenge that is to
come up with your own definition that
comes up against it what are we saying
that's an object that has location so
again if god wants to exist god has to
have distance with respect to every
object in the universe there better be a
straight line of direction from me to
god okay
god can hide again in the 10th dimension
or i'm sorry string theory 26 dimension
he can hide in the 27th dimension for
all i care there's got to be a straight
line of direction from me to him
he can't away no matter no matter where
he goes okay so sorry god
you want to exist you got to have
distance
okay that's that's the way it is
separation
okay so we have these definitions um and
here
we see
just a clarification of something okay
that
a lot of people confuse
science with materialism physics with
materialism especially that
especially dias accuse
many mathematical physicists
saying oh you're a materialist
it turns out that they're not
you know and here you see why these
definitions come from the wikipedia
materialism holds that the only things
that exist are matter and energy
well we have no problem with matter we
say that objects that exist are matter
but we do have a big problem with energy
no such monster is energy not in physics
it's a concept and we cannot say that
energy exists so if that's the
definition of materialism okay um
then it's not what we have in science
it's not what we have in physics okay so
materialism
under that notion that definition is
divorced from physics okay
if they would have stopped that matter
that would have been okay okay and the
idealism holds that the only things that
exist are thoughts and ideas well
obviously not not under physics
we
reject that thoughts and ideas are
concepts and concepts cannot be said to
exist not in science not in physics you
can say that at the church you know in
in your sunday school no problem
scholasticism existence of a thing is
not derived from its essence but is
determined by the creative volition of
god
my god
yeah they have all these notions out
there different people who believe
different things that's why i forget
about facts
fact is what you believe in that's what
it is
how do we say it what is rationalism
what is rational in
in science and physics well here we have
a definition that
opposes materialism
and its physics holds that energy is a
concept therefore in science it is
irrational to say that a concept
exists and likewise it is irrational to
say that concepts such as thoughts and
ideas exist okay so this is
the answer to that
okay um some people say hey bill how
about your threads because some people
have raised this issue and they say your
threads is there a single thread in the
universe and i say yes as far as i know
or as far as the hypothesis goes there's
a single thread there could be another
universe made of a parallel thread
another thread that's
you know not connected to any of the
atoms of our in other words
every atom in the universe and the ropes
that interconnect them under the rope
hypothesis all that's wound by a single
all that's weaved by a single thread
we're saying there's a single thread in
the unit in the entire universe and that
underlies all matter okay that's the
foundation that's a hypothesis that's
the assumption okay and from there we
build these theories based on how the
atom works how gravity works and so on
but there's a single thread if we could
have mined every atom if we could unwind
every rope in the universe if we had the
power of god to do that right
then we would end up with a single
thread closed loop thread okay that's
that's the notion that we have so people
say okay you have a single thread okay
you can think of it as a maybe like a
rubber band okay something like this
okay that's it that's what we're saying
we have out there that's how complicated
the universe is
okay so now you know
and so the people say okay you have a
single thread
but that single thread has no location
because it has no reference it has no
distance with respect to anything
outside of it
and that's absolutely correct
now we could have this situation here
let me show you okay we could have a
second thread out there
our universe is the one on the right the
other one's the one on the left okay so
there could be a universe out there with
all the atoms made up by one thread and
we have our universe with all the atoms
and ropes made by our thread right there
could be a difference in the speed of
light because maybe there's more matter
over there
maybe uh
that's a
speed of light maybe a function in the
ultimately of how long the thread is you
know and maybe they have a different
length of this thread and so they might
have a different uh speed of light over
there but certainly we would not capture
any of the light from that universe
because
no atom in that universe is connected
through electromagnetic threads to any
of the atoms in our universe the only
way we can see
or touch is through atoms in other words
through atoms through the rope two atom
to another robe and so on if none of the
atoms in that universe are connected to
the ones in our universe we have no
connection to that universe
now meanwhile does our universe exist
we have to follow the definition
whenever in trouble whenever you don't
know whenever you have you know a blank
in your mind just follow the definition
people don't understand that they
they give lip service to the definition
they say oh how about this and how about
that
follow the definition if you follow the
definition
i promise you that you will not get hurt
okay just follow the definition what is
the definition
it says that you need an object and you
need location what is location set of
distances here we have no here we have
def uh distance between those two
threads therefore both of those threads
exist by definition scientific
definition not the one of ordinary
speech not the notion of ordinary speech
they exist by definition there's you
have objects and you have distance okay
so far so good
okay
now what happens if we have this
situation right
okay now in this case we have only a
single thread now we don't have that
though that other thread to have this
distance with respect to it okay so now
we seem to be in a lot of trouble
because
you know people say well hold it our
thread it's the only thread in the
universe right space and thread that's
all we have
and it turns out that this thread makes
up everything that exists
and what are you telling me that
everything that exists is based on
something that doesn't exist
is that what you're saying
you know so and the issue here is again
people are reverting to ordinary speech
that's the whole problem here the whole
problem is people are thinking again
they're using language of ordinary
speech they're thinking and see touch
again and they're saying hold it we can
see and touch everything in our universe
that exists and you're saying this when
we can't see or touch it has no distance
so it doesn't exist
and and it makes up everything that
exists
yes you have to go by the definition
just go by the definition and i promise
not to hurt you
just go
by the definition the definition says
that it has to be an object
okay it's got to have distance
if it doesn't have distance with respect
to another thread another universe
then it doesn't exist by definition
pursuant to the definition okay
so
it is a meaningless it's a trivial thing
in physics
because
what we use in physics every day are
atoms and we're saying this atom exists
because it has distance with respect to
this other atom okay and we can go
around with everything that's that is
out there all the atoms you can even say
the rope exists because there is a
distance between ropes even though we
don't measure between ropes we measure
between atoms and so we have the notion
that distance is only between atoms so
the distance between atoms is
essentially the length of the rope and
we do not think in terms of oh the
distance between two energies which is
what people imagine like to be
you know
what kind of answer is that saying that
you have a distance between two energies
nobody would talk like that and the same
thing here
here we have a this a separation between
ropes so it does have existence in that
sense but we never think of energy which
is what people think the rope is uh in
terms of existence in terms of distance
okay
terms of location
that's the problem but whenever people
say oh but the thread doesn't exist
because it's a single thread there's no
distance to any other thread outside of
it yeah it's a trivial issue just follow
the definition and you can safely say
that the single thread that makes up all
the matter in the universe that thread
doesn't exist that does not mean that
does not entail that the atoms of which
it's that are made of that thread do not
exist
okay
and i hope someone understood that out
there okay
okay so uh
let's move on here to
the the science critic that we had uh
thought came over and he criticized the
scientific method and we're probably
going to get to the word existence with
him as well
eventually
but uh this time around he talked about
something else he talked about
what is it the
uh falsifiability and uh the fact that
you need um uh to evidence some kind of
evidence i guess he was thinking of some
kind of experiment or something
okay so here let me turn him on this is
uh
this is what he said go let's go slowly
here
the questions and issues addressed in
this rebuttal include
what does it mean to say that a theory
is rational
and
does the rationality of an explanation
depend on falsifiability
and evidence
and when it comes to a rational theory
i'd say that a rational theory would
have to be falsifiable and consistent
with evidence if it does not fit any of
those two criteria then it is irrational
okay
so uh he thinks it's all related to
falsifiability
and um evidence
but as we just covered it a minute ago a
falsifiability has to do with belief and
evidence has to do with belief and
belief is not science belief is religion
so obviously this poor fellow you know
he was educated in a monastery somewhere
you know uh he learned all this i guess
from the priests and you know that's the
best i can think of because why would he
talk about falsifiability
and um
and evidence you know uh you know when a
prosecutor tries to convince you he
presents you know evidence to the juror
to you if you're the juror
and he's just trying to convince you
so he presents evidence and if you
believe the evidence yeah you
sign up to you vote for his case you
know none of that has anything to do
with science uh legal world is all
religion it's all about belief how many
people have been sentenced uh
erroneously among them me
yeah a lot of people get sent to the uh
death chamber you know and it turns out
they were innocent they found out years
later that the guy had nothing to do
with it but the juror believed the
theory
despite that later on they found out
true evidence referred to her evidence
that the guy was innocent so it was a
fact when he went to prison
and then they found out it was not a
fact that there's a different fact so we
have all these facts
all these beliefs they're known as
beliefs
okay so let's look at this father he
says falsifiability okay here it is we
look it up and says falsifiable able to
be proven false okay what is false not
true
okay
and what's proved to establish the truth
by evidence or argument
and what is true well conformity with
fact
or reality not false
what's truth a verified or indisputable
fact what is fact something that
actually exists reality truth
reality the state of qua or quality of
being real
uh
and what is real it's true
look it up it's got to do with truth and
finally we have evidence that which
tends to prove or disprove right to whom
i don't know maybe to the pope something
ground for belief yes
proof
so all we did was just go around in
circle all he had was synonym we don't
know what falsifiability means because
it's got to do with uh proving something
false and all those are synonyms
so we have no idea what this fellow poor
fellow is talking about and so i have to
believe that you know maybe just maybe
um this fellow didn't use his brain very
much in
in school or
monastery i don't know where he where he
went you know and uh you know i don't
think he used his cpu very much i think
he used his rom his random
his read-only memory i'm sorry read-only
memory that's all he's got just
memorized all this stuff in in school he
had no use for his brain apparently he
just sat and warmed the desk and
received this you know
by word of mouth that's it he just
listened to it and he never
analyzed it
on his own he never criticized he never
attacked it he just accepted himself on
the basis of what authority okay so this
is how these people work
and yeah what can i say
again rationality here we have it for
those who are interested what is
irrational well treating concepts as
objects that's what rationality is
rationality has nothing to do or
irrationality has nothing to do with
you know verifying or
or falsifying we don't falsify anything
in science we try not to it's the other
way around we try to
you know unfalsify things you know not
falsify them and we certainly don't use
evidence because evidence is just there
to convince you no irrational means that
you're going to move concepts around
such as you know time dilation you know
dilate time
that's scary stuff and you're gonna
go with a force you know
transfer the energy
weigh the
mass
yeah that's a primary one the first one
there but then you know you're using
inconsistent definitions or undefined
words which is
just about all the words in mathematics
are all undefined they
finally say well
words you need more words to define
those words and those words need to be
defined as well so we cannot define any
word that's their answer it's just uh
circular or infinite as they said
infinite argument
and so they never define words and
they're satisfied with that they say
yeah you get a the bug has to stop
somewhere but it doesn't then it just
goes on and on and on so we don't define
any words and they have no definition
for any of those words
no look up field field is defined as a
value at each point in space
and then they say the field moved the
charge
what do you mean the field move the
charges like a paddle you know
no you can't do that charge is a is a
number 1.6 times 10 to the minus 19
coulombs right that that's the value of
a charge and you're going to move this
number
with this paddle called the field a
bunch of numbers a bunch of values in
each
at each point in space
no you're not allowed to do that that's
known as irrationality
okay so let's move on here to some of
the uh questions i know first we got the
moonies hold it forgot the moonies today
okay here it goes uh what was the issue
with the moonies well
moonies are people who believe that we
did not go to the moon okay
and i'm on record i'm gonna say that i'm
gonna confess here right that uh after
uh looking at a couple of these videos
they put the seed of doubt in me or at
least made it very interesting to look
it up doesn't mean i stopped believing
that we went to the moon i just
concluded that i cannot answer all the
questions
that people
have brought up okay so
i'm on record for that i can't say that
i understand all these issues okay how
they how some of these things were done
like you know you see the guy on the
moon jumping around and i showed that
the other day
uh
and you slow it down
and that's a normal hop
like that you could do here on earth
with wires
you know so the guy jumps in fact in
that case you didn't even need wires i
think you could do that and just slow
down the movie which is what i did uh i
just
slowed it down 50 by 50 percent you know
and suddenly you're on the moon you know
you're jumping very slowly so that you
know you didn't even need wires for that
and so you say well could have that been
done
in a studio
and my answer is yes uh without any you
know doubts about it i have no
reservations about that it could have
been done in a
studio now was that one done in a studio
or this guy jump on the moon because
after all think about it you know if
he's going to be on the moon he's going
to jump around that's also what it's
going to look like
so
if they show you the real thing and the
fake one how are you supposed to tell
the difference okay keep that in mind as
well but what's my argument my argument
is that
you know in fact let me let me show you
that
down here because a guy raised that
issue okay
and he said the following he said
he said here the topic of discussion is
whether the apollo missions are fake or
whether man has ever set foot on the
moon
okay
what does the satellite or the probe or
the rover meaning the iss right i guess
he was referring to that have to do with
it did armstrong set foot on the moon or
not
okay so uh because i brought the issue
of um
of
the iss
and uh so this is what i've got to
answer him okay
here it is
okay
it's the the uh levels of incredulity
that we find out there among munis okay
this is a big problem because you have
munis who say that we didn't go to the
moon others say that uh humans can't
even pass the van allen belts others say
probes never went to the moon or to any
of the planets like mercury or
or venus or mars
and others say that they never even went
into outer space they didn't even reach
what is known as the low earth orbit uh
you know some believe we never even went
to
low earth orbit okay
and
some don't even believe that there are
satellites out there and i know a lot of
flat earthers are on that wave because
they of course if you can show that you
have satellites you could you could
conceivably take a picture from the
satellite of the earth and show that
it's a sphere and so they have to deny
that there are even satellites out there
and
others believe the iss is fake and why
do i pick on the iss well because the
iss is something anyone can verify with
a pair of binoculars or with a telescope
that's why i chose the iss i mean forget
about all these other people going to
the moon in 1969 if these people don't
believe the iss is out there right now
when they can focus with their
binoculars you're never going to
convince about about men going to the
moon so we have to forget about man to
the moon we've got a bigger fire here
raging and that's that these people
don't believe in the iss
and um and then there's others who
believe that the iss is out there but
there are no humans in the iss they say
that's the part that's fake all the
zero gravity stuff okay
and so that's why i say we can't settle
the iss which can be verified by
telescope binoculars today it is a waste
of warp space time to discuss the moon
landings
okay so that's my take on this
okay so what do some of these people say
okay here's one fellow and he says
about gravity in low earth orbit he says
few things you did not consider okay
gravity is at 250 miles above the earth
is only
five five percent less so far uh so it's
far from close to zero gravity
and he's right uh surface of the earth
you get 9.8 meters per second square if
you go to low earth orbit approximately
250 miles or 400 kilometers thereabouts
uh you get nine meters per second square
acceleration
so not much difference you know from
nine to nine point eight you know you
don't have much difference what's the
catch what's the difference well more or
less what you see in those airplanes
that have zero gravity for about 20
seconds because they go on a parabola
okay and here you see it the pull of
gravity is
in low earth orbit is only slightly less
than on the earth's surface true this is
because the distance to the
leo right from the earth's surface is
much less than the earth's radius okay
however an object in orbit is by
definition in free fall
remember einstein and his elevator
following the man i would not know if
he's going up or down or whatever
since there is no force holding it up
that's the situation up there okay as a
result objects in orbit including people
experience a sense of weightlessness
there you have the link
okay so uh the fact that uh the gravity
is not that much difference
different at 250
miles
from the surface of the earth
does not negate that they're going to be
floating around they're floating around
for a different reason okay and there
you have it
okay another fellow says okay
like some of these uh notions that these
people raised well says the speed of the
iss travel is 17 kilometers uh or 17 000
miles per hour okay way too fast for an
amateur video you showed and at 250
miles above the earth it is obstructed
by over 700 miles of earth curvature
to have direct line of sight to the sun
well at least uh the guy's not a flat
earther okay so how is it illuminated uh
most likely the video is from some high
altitude balloon
and again let's show the video okay i
don't know what these people have in
their heads here it is the guy is
filming through his telescope
okay you might well this was done in a
studio right there's the guy he's
filming himself from behind how he's
filming
the the uh
iss he takes a picture of it
you don't have to believe him you can
get your own set of binoculars and prove
to yourself you know convince yourself
that uh there is a monster out there
orbiting the earth okay
now if you're like galileo you know or
you know the really the cardinals of
galileo who refuse to look through his
telescope at the galilean
moons you know
io and so on
uh
if you refuse to look well you know i
can't help you this guy is filming
you know the iss from the ground and he
i think he's here in germany
and he's filming it so
you know you don't have to believe him
but go get your binoculars if you're
gonna say that he faked it that he did
it in a studio he did it with a hot air
balloon or whatever i mean come on
how far are these people gonna take this
that's the question and and that's the
these are the people who destroy really
the conversation because they're so
extreme in their thoughts that you can't
even have a conversation with them
again it's known as a fact
you know it's a fact and some people
don't believe those facts and there you
have it some people don't believe the
iss you show them the iss through the
telescope through the year binoculars
you take them to the iss and they still
don't believe
i don't believe that fact it's not a
fact no you took me to disneyland yeah
okay
okay the trick is done by performing a
parabolic flight path a cra the craft
falls with a people and things inside
falling too
so he thinks that this i guess
here's an example right
ah
sorry
give him a second here
i'll show you some zero gravity here
okay here it is
uh mueller
and you can see he's flying around
and why because he went on this airplane
in france
that uh takes people for a ride through
a tourist ride uh it's zero gravity for
20 seconds approximately and then they
all fall down okay
so this is what it is it's not a trick
this is not done in a studio this is the
real thing folks
and uh should we say that this was done
in a studio too that they took the
trouble i mean everything is fake today
right so that probably was done in
studio
and yeah this is what people believe
that you know the iss you know
the things that they do in there going
from one chamber to another that's all
done in a studio with wires they took
all this trouble to do that
i mean i think it's much easier much way
more easier to do it on the iss than it
would be in hollywood okay so someone
says the following he criticizes the
water drop here it goes says there are
plenty of examples of the kinds of
motion and activity such as drinking a
glob of water or realistic
floating objects that you have claimed
couldn't be faked in a studio found in
movies and tv shows okay he said proof
drinking a floating water globe uh
global uh in a similar manner can be
seen on the tv show the expanse and he
says look up the expand zero gravity
time killing so i did look it up and
this is what you that you see in that
movie the specific uh
strip of film where the guy uh drinks a
drop of water that's flooding in air
okay
okay and here he is yeah
he throws that uh
i guess his uh pop bottle
pop can
turns around okay i did it in fast
motion there and here he swallows the
drops of water as they come into his
mouth but you can see the drops of water
are really going straight
okay
and so people confuse things and they
say okay that can be done in a studio
this can be done in a studio the guy
rolling around with a belt uh tied to a
wire but this you can see the drops of
water just floating by straight
he doesn't play around with them compare
that now with this the
iss
what is it
astronaut the lady who swallowed the
water compare this against this now
this is a lot different i'm not sure uh
hollywood can do this
okay not in a studio
not that neat not that clear
okay and you can see that she's fumbling
with that water drop like anything
you're saying how how did she do that in
a studio that's the one i want you to
show me this other fella he's just got
drops of water floating
past them here you see it again let me
show you one more time
okay you just get the weather drops just
floating around you know
that can be done in a studio no no
problem with that but this this is
something different this is what did
they do they held it held that water
droplet with a string is that how they
did it
and so again people are going to
extremes
to try to
argue their case against the iss i mean
i think it would be much easier for them
to do it in the iss then
you know what you see
then to do it in hollywood
that's my five cents worth on that what
can i tell you
uh these people i think are going out of
their way we do have an iss we in order
to take it up there there had to be some
intermediate steps there had to be many
prod
you know
rockets sent with all these uh probes
out there before we could build an iss
out there in space
and if we built that thing up there so
we just have that like this other fella
said tin can
or
uh tuna can
uh orbiting the earth
um
what can i tell you it's empty there's
nothing in there they just put this tin
can up there and everybody just watches
it just to fool the entire earth
my god these people are really taking it
very far and they're really flat
earthers that's what they are
okay
another foul says
um
look up nasa engineer kelly smith
videos on youtube who admits we can't
get through the deadly van allen belts
today
well i did look that fellow up i didn't
find uh the
he had a couple videos i watched couple
of them and then i
finished
i didn't look for more first of all he
didn't come across as a very reliable
fellow for me
he was there
primarily to boast that he got a job at
nasa and like you know
eat your heart out that sort of thing
he's just
putting a show where he's collecting
money to say hey you know i got a job at
nasa and you don't that's all it was and
then he talked about a lot of his you
know how he got his master's degree and
so on quite boring the whole thing i
couldn't find
the specific piece where he says about
the van allen belt so i would need a
link
to that video
to find out what he's talking about but
again he didn't come across as very
reliable and you know a lot of stuff he
said was just
he's a newbie he doesn't know anything
he's supposedly an engineer
but he's uh he's just starting out
you know so
yeah i was not i was by no means
convinced by that fellow okay
appoint someone that knows a little more
maybe
that can express himself a lot better
than this fellow
okay let's go now yes with the questions
okay follows us
he says plasma could you explain why
you're why you regard plasma as a
concept and not an object
or could you point me to somewhere
you've explained it previously i
explained it several times in fact but
no problem here it is uh
i won't go through all that just uh
answer his question why is plasma an
object and
a concept and not an object there it is
and it is uh plasma is defined as
ionized okay that's what plasma plasma
is iodized now ionize is not a physical
object okay ionize is if you say i i
ionize something you use a verb but as
uh as a qualifier it's an adverb
and so there's no physical object called
ionized okay that's the issue and don't
put any more words
in there that's the definition ionize
you got to focus on that word if you put
more words all you're doing is getting
confused okay plasma is equal to ionized
and ionized is not a physical object now
some people define plasma even worse
they say it's the fourth state of matter
well hopefully if plasma is the fourth
state of matter there's no physical
standalone object called forced state of
matter
so again it's people who don't pay
attention to definitions like the
electric universe you know that likes to
use this word plasma
you know
[Music]
there is no physical object called
ionize that there is no physical object
stand-alone object called state of
matter okay in fact uh this is very
easily see and and you can see it there
in the uh little
pictures on the right uh
gas is a physical object okay because
you don't have to have gas moving in
order
for it to be a physical object plasma
needs to move you need to have a movie
to watch
plasma you can't see
plasma in a photograph what you're
seeing there is arrows what are those
arrows represent motion
okay so you're seeing
a movie inside a picture that's what
they illustrated there and unless you
understand that it means you you don't
have the mental capacity to be in
physics okay those arrows are motion you
cannot have plasma in a picture
they illustrated with these arrows just
to give you the idea that those uh
atoms are or n electrons are moving
and that's what plasma is plasma means
ionized that's what it means and if you
think ions is a standalone object well
god have mercy on your soul
okay
okay another fellow says
uh an accurate estimate of how many
atoms are in the known universe is a
minimum of 10 to the 78th power and a
maximum of 10 to the 82nd power blah
blah blah blah blah okay how many ropes
would that be physically connecting adam
to all other atoms uh-huh a bazillion
gazillion or a whole bunch a whole bunch
probably
is an absolutely unacceptable answer as
an engineer
okay so here's uh my answer to this
gentleman
and
the first thing is that you know this is
not a question of science not a question
of physics as he said it's a question
for an engineer maybe you know maybe a
mathematician not a scientist not a
physicist okay we don't do math in
science okay
and uh
besides an estimate is not accurate okay
so it's uh you know uh if if you're
gonna talk about an accurate estimate
you have already an oxymoron there okay
but an engineer is unconcerned with
atoms in the universe that's not the job
of an engineer i know i was an engineer
for many years
and we didn't count atoms of course that
was not my my engineering specialty but
you know any engineer engineers don't
count atoms out there in the universe
that's not their job okay so he's asking
a question uh
of engineering
and to a physicist
so he's he's in the wrong shift
engineering has to do with technology
physicist has to do with science okay
and technology and science are two
different
fields two different disciplines one has
nothing at all to do with the other
technology they develop gadgets by trial
and error science we explain mechanisms
nothing to do one with the other
physicists is not interested in how much
at all and and engineer is a guy who
designs and builds gadgets that's all it
is
so you know when all these people
give these numbers out and they want to
play around with numbers they're in the
wrong field you know i don't i don't
know what they're doing in in science
i guess they missed the wrong door down
the hall bud
go down the hall you'll find engineering
over there okay
technology r d
okay another
fellow i think it's the same vowel says
based on knowing the size of the
electron expressed in plank length what
diameter is the electric side of this
intertwined row
the diameter of both sections
intertwined the diameter of the
fundamental element threat comprising
them well again uh you know
fellows are asking questions that are
not part of science it's not part of
physics here it is this is not a
question of physics physics does is not
interested in how much physics deals
with explanations of causes and
mechanisms okay
uh types of questions that a physicist
deals with is what caused the pen to
fall to the ground not how many atoms
does the pen have okay
estimate again not equal to accurate
accurate so to say you know some an
accurate estimate is wrong the bread and
butter of physics is
the object okay not the numbers we don't
deal with numbers we deal with objects
okay
mechanisms are done with objects causes
are done with objects so uh again you
know i don't know why these people even
come
to a physics site if they're going to
ask questions of engineering or
technology which are unrelated to this
channel
we have nothing to do with those
it's like
asking about you know
tourism here you know we don't do
tourism here i do some tourists every
night but i don't talk about tourism you
know so if you come say bill
how do you travel to china
sorry uh
take the next american airlines flight
or whatever
okay uh here's another felony he says
forget the rope hypothesis it's simply
physically impossible whoa physically
impossible
okay let's answer him
unsustainable
unsubstantiated opinion that's what he's
doing he just used words that he doesn't
even understand okay
and physical is not equal to c touch so
maybe that's what he's got wrong into
his uh being brain okay
physical is equal to object to a thing
okay what is the thing is it with that
which you can see and touch no it's that
which has shape the rope
hypothesis the electromagnetic rope has
shape it cannot be seen or touched so i
don't know why he says it's simply
physically impossible when physically
means object okay it is an object so
what's impossible about it until he can
you know
make sense of his statement all we have
is unsubstantiated opinion
uh and again you know the
electromagnetic rope is invisible and
tangible and it is a physical object
therefore i don't know what he means by
it's simply physically impossible
can't help you but
uh until you clarify why it's physically
impossible okay you gotta
specify that
okay another foul says being able to see
nanoparticles and atoms since the 1980s
by a transmission electron microscope
scanning tunneling microscopes and
atomic force microscopes right
how and why would the visible tangible
have to be made of invisible intangible
well the the first thing i have to
believe this fellow is uh from mars or
you know from some other planet
i mean he says being able to see
nanoparticles and atoms since the 1980s
you know that that's interesting
i think this proves that we do have
aliens that have invaded the earth okay
well here's uh my answer um you know
it's an irrational question
uh because um
uh you know the questions of purpose
he's talking about uh there how and why
would the visible intangible have to be
made of invisible intangible well it's a
question of purpose he's talking about
why in the in the sense of purpose not
in the sense of causes okay purpose and
reasons that's philosophy and the answer
to that is always the same because god
made it that way
no human has ever seen an atom
not a human in fact uh the atom today is
illustrated by you know mathematicians
here on earth that's why we should
notify this alien here this et
that you know this is the model we have
today from
uh quantum mechanics and that's the one
you see down there you have the three
quarks that form a ball known as a
proton
and then you have the electron bead
which goes around it this is the atom
they use to
explain electricity uh this is the atom
they use to explain ionization this is
the anime used to explain quantum jump
and so this is the atom we have because
we've never seen an atom and
this fella says that since the 1980s
they have seen
nanoparticles and atoms so i guess it
must have been on his planet i wish he
could draw it for us so that we knew
or point to you know some
link in his planet uh that we could see
what an atom looks like you know we've
never seen one here on earth at least
you know
so all i can ask him is to please
illustrate it you know put a link to
your planet so that we can see what an
atom looks like we absolutely want to
see
what an atom looks like okay
and when i say an atom i mean like
i want to see what the electron looks
like is is it an orbiting bead like
going around like the hydrogen atom
that's the type of thing we're looking
for right and no we've never seen an
atom
uh
they've taken bird's eye pictures of big
atoms
and again it's bird's eye
and the funny thing is they all look
good like this
like a ball
and why would it look like a ball if
it's an orbiting bead
you would think it would look more like
you know a little bead rolling around
a smaller ball or something like that
that's not what you observe when they
take pictures it's all balls
uh from a bird's eye perspective again
uh that's why we have not seen inside
the atom we don't know what the proton
looks like for example okay
uh and if you can't see the proton you
can't see the electron
uh some people boast that they've been
able to film the electron they show some
wavy thing there and of course that's
nonsense because the electron is said to
be point particle it's got no no
dimensions no size
so you figure it out
okay but uh let's answer this fella's
question anyways okay because there is
an element there he asks
how is that intangibility produces
tangibility how is it that invisibility
produces visibility
and the question the issue there is that
you cannot see one atom
but you can see the chair and you can
see the table
and the chair in the table are made of
many atoms
but again you cannot see one atom
and you want proof of that those people
who want evidence and
a little more than belief you know proof
knowledge or whatever it's called
you can't see the air the air is made
out of atoms
period we're done
see how easy it was we can't see the air
it's made of gazillions of atoms
floating around here and we can't see
any of them
and so no we cannot see all objects we
cannot see
the atoms the oxygen
atoms we cannot see the oxygen molecules
o2 right
and plus the other garbage nitrogen
whatever is in the air right
and so we cannot see these molecules let
alone the atoms
and so this is so so this takes us to
how mother nature does this how she
produces tangibility from intangibility
how she produces visibility from
invisibility okay here it is okay the
way we do it is all objects that we can
see or touch in everyday experience are
made of many atoms we would not see a
chair
if it were made of one atom the key is
aggregation
we cannot see or touch the threads that
comprise the electromagnetic rope you
can prove this to yourself by you know
get a
a
spoon like i did earlier right
let me show you here give me a second
okay
and so here we have
a spoon
okay you cannot see
the things that are connecting it to the
earth
see or touch i mean if you can let me
know but i can't see her touch okay i'm
touching the air but i don't see the air
and i can't touch whatever is holding
the
uh spoon
prisoner to the earth
so the only reason the thing the spoon
doesn't fall is because i'm holding it
up i'm preventing its fall i'm stronger
than whatever is pulling on it but as
soon as i let go of it something pulls
on it
and yes gravity is a pull force
to use that word and
magnetism is a full force you can prove
this to yourself also
evidence yeah proof fact
just by taking two magnets and you'll
feel that the tug is from the inside
okay you'll see that nothing's pushing
on your hand something is tugging from
the inside
and there's something there that you
cannot see or touch
the issue is aggregation when you put a
lot of these threads together like you
know when you build a ball known as an
electron which encapsulates the proton
star that's when you can start
looking at talking about c and touch not
yet with an electron sphere meaning the
atom you need several atoms for us to
see it to get that frequency and yes
when you have many atoms now you can see
the thing you can see the chair the
table whatever it's all aggregation okay
so religious people have invented
spirits and angels as mediators to
explain gravity and magnetism
the idiots of math right instead use
mathematical concepts such as field wave
energy mass and other
nonsense
okay another question here fellow says
uh the other i know i was answering this
well as well okay the electromagnetic
rope forks out at the boundary of the
electron shell and the electron shell is
weaved by countless threads okay it is
this aggregation of threads that confers
the nascent
emergent property of sea and touch to
the atom and still we need many atoms to
have the ability to see touch the chair
we can't see the air in spite of this
aggregation of atoms it is seed touch
which has fooled the theorists
throughout the ages okay
and here you have the picture of what
i'm talking about a picture of our atom
okay you have a two-dimensional one
there and a three-dimensional one there
thanks to dave and dan for that okay
and um
and there you see how it's built you
have all these uh ropes converging upon
our atom and one rope turns into the
elect
electron which is an electron membrane
it's a it's a
like a ball balloon that encapsulates
the proton star which is what you see in
the center so the yellow one is a star
that's the proton and one that
encapsulated is the
electro the electron
and yeah you have gazillions of atoms
converging upon that atom that's what
builds it and so our atom is connected
to every atom in the universe and that
scares a lot of people because they say
well how can the numbers how how do you
account for the numbers and that's
what's troubling them they said so many
well uh i hate to tell them first of all
you know that
in just a little cubic centimeter
of uh of what i have here air
there's
thousands and thousands of atoms
and how can that possibly be just a
little bit yeah
the atom is so small that you have
thousands hundreds of thousands in a
cubic centimeter
of air
and you say how can that possibly i
can't even see it with there being
hundreds of thousands in this region
here yeah
and you can't see them
and and so you can't see one atom
but you can imagine if you build up a
lot of these atoms now that they you
built a surface
the electron surface which is a
globular type of surface it's a balloon
it's a uh
encapsulating membrane okay
now you can you can start you can't see
that yet okay you can't see that yet but
what you have is when you have many of
those at some point this aggregation is
what builds up and that's what builds
sea and touch
uh
visibility tangibility okay so that's
the way it works it's through
aggregation that's how
intangibility becomes tangible
visibility becomes visible
invisibility becomes visible
okay paul says time dilation isn't just
theoretical
global positioning satellites have to
take it into effect to provide accurate
readings to users here on earth
theoretical has to do with science has
nothing to do with time dilation time
dilation is not theoretical especially
if it's got to do with what with users
you know reading users that's got to do
with technology so
to say theoretical
and it's got to do with this users no
you've got a contradiction there okay no
it's got nothing to do with it and then
uh he said time passes more slowly close
to a massive object whoa it's so scary
when time passes by you know
it's really scary you know it's a
concept that's moving so time passes
i want whatever he's got
bartender
does a lot of good to him then he says a
clock on earth's surface ticks at a
slower rate relative to one
on a satellite in orbit
absolutely not
whoever told you that einstein
i mean you're not going to believe
einstein you know here i'll show you
bill's uh clock okay we're going to use
bill's clock here okay
this is bill gates ir hourglass dilation
okay and the clock that's closer to the
center of the earth
is going faster and the guy on the
outside is going slower
so i'm not sure what problem this fall
has in understanding this
obviously clocks closer to the center of
the earth go faster because of gravity
and those that are farther away go
slower we're done i mean i'm not sure
where he got this notion
that uh it's the other way around okay
so
yeah uh we just have to use uh the
proper gravitational clocks and yes um
an hourglass is a gravitational clock so
it's the best
clock to relate time with gravity okay
okay another fellow says uh it is
amazing that time passes more slowly
another guy that has time passed i
wonder what these guys drink i mean it
passes time passes for me time never
passes okay on earth and that time
speeds up
on the satellite clock
how does time or the speed of light
cause all the clocks on earth to slow
down
my poor god this poor fellow
where do these people get all this stuff
okay here's the answer okay
you had better have first a physical
entity if you're gonna talk about uh
affecting something else there is no
action at a distance much less from a
concept such as time you have to talk
about clocks
not time okay and that's where people
get confused because time does not
belong to physics clocks belong to
physics
and hopefully uh you know if that clock
runs fl faster or slower out there in
space compared to one down here on earth
hopefully it's got to do with some
connection with the earth physical
connection because otherwise you're
going to be doing black magic you're
going to say that there's nothing
between the clock and the earth and yet
the earth somehow affects that clock how
does it affect it
by magic black magic what are you going
to use the word field are you going to
use the word energy
what concept are you gonna use
no you have to use a physical object and
there we have a physical object we're
saying that one atom of the clock is
connected to every atom on earth that's
just one atom of the clock every atom of
that clock is connected to every atom of
the earth
and you say well bill where in the world
did you get this well let's just put
some
uh
evidence
some proof
some authority especially here's
authority here's richard miller you see
berkeley so for example if you have the
earth here there's a big mass here and
you have you with your little mass here
every atom on the earth is what
pulling on every atom of you you're also
pulling an n the amazing thing about
gravity is that it goes right through
things
okay so there you have your explanation
of why every atom of the clock is
connected to every atom on earth and
every atom of the earth is connected to
every atom of that clot
that's the only way you can explain why
the earth affects the clock okay
otherwise uh you're using black magic
you're saying that it does so by remote
control
nothing in between
and it turns out that this
uh earth you know whatever earth does is
affecting that clock the earth is
affecting the moon the sun is affecting
the earth and everything's done by
remote control
yeah sure
yeah
even even sun tan is done with physical
object the rope that's the
drills uh you know it's drilling a hole
through the torsion on the atoms it's
torquing them that's what it's doing
there otherwise you know if there were
no connection between the sun and your
body why would you get a suntan
waves
frequency
maybe amplitude i don't know you tell me
why would you get a suntan
what's stimulating your atoms in your
body if not a physical entity that is in
contact with your body the ropes
okay so here we have another file says
just memorizing uh what you read will
not help you get a grade okay
we talked about uh uh studying
and i'm saying that uh
a lot of people the way we all learn
even from being babies we learn by road
we just repeat what our
elders
fed us
and when we go to high school in college
we read books
written by people who
came before us okay and so they come up
and and they discovered things certain
patterns in nature they put them in
books you read the book and you learn
what this guy taught you so it's all
done by rote and this guy's uh
protesting he says well that's not the
way you learn yeah i agree that's the
way you memorize okay
and so he says you have to do
experiments do papers and many other
things to show that you understand
understood what you read and are able to
use the knowledge and to do experiments
now experiments are technology has
nothing to do with
physics with understanding like you know
science
based on the knowledge again belief
okay knowledge is believed to see if
it's correct or wrong that's an opinion
we don't care about opinions
yes we first had to learn and memorize
the basic thank you
in chemistry for example right but that
was only a small portion oh small
portion i thought it was 100
after that we had to do experiments to
see if what is
predicted is correct again predicted
correct
religion
no it's got nothing to do with
prediction we're talking about
understanding did you understand can you
explain
and again uh if if you're just
regurgitating what you read in the book
and the fact that you can regurgitate it
well
that's that's not studying
it's not rationalizing something when
you rationalize something you do it on
your own you don't do it because you
read a book you take and you
get all the things that you read and you
put them like together in your mind and
you create your own thoughts
that's the way then then we know you're
you're working your brain out there it
means you can you have the material to
be a scientist but if you just got a phd
because you warmed a desk for 10 years
and you can
spit out what they fed you especially
your
advisor you better better be able to
otherwise you don't get your phd right
you know if you can just regurgitate
what you learn
by rote that's a that's not science and
certainly that's not studying that's not
you know what is that that's just memory
again no cpu just
rom
most just memorizing things won't do you
any good in science at least in germany
well i'm in germany and the same garbage
is here that's all around the world okay
so to say that there's something
different in germany than in every
country in the world you know you'll
have to prove that to me okay
okay uh false says again with facts like
all these christians out there who
believe the earth and the whole universe
is just six thousand year old facts
would make their belief wrong and that
that they can't accept so facts are the
enemy of belief
and again he doesn't understand doesn't
understand doesn't understand he can he
can come up with all the evidence all
the proof all the uh
experiments whatever he brings
and the guy on the other side says no i
don't believe i don't believe i don't
believe i don't believe in your facts
and he just dies saying i don't believe
in your facts no matter what
and what's this girl going to do uh kill
them
so facts are belief okay
and so if you do a measurement got a
different result than me then we can
talk about where the difference comes
from yeah and we if we don't agree then
we don't have a fact
and he said but look in here and look
through the telescope you'll see the
moons of jupiter and i'll say i don't
want to look through your stupid
telescope i don't believe there are any
moons in jupiter
period
what are you going to do you say no but
it's a fact yeah i don't want to believe
and
so no he doesn't understand facts are
believed we don't have facts in science
we have statements of the fact fact is
what mother nature has
she knows what happened exactly we can
only speculate and based on that you
know make statements of the fact
according to what we think really
happened
okay your rope hypothesis is conceptual
uh-oh
you do realize there is an incalculable
possibly infinite number of atoms in the
universe my god infinite
how could infinite in uh idiocy that's
what we see here how could every single
atom fit that infinite number of threads
okay you know that's just physically
impossible right physically what is all
the what are these words that this
fellow poor fellow is using okay so here
we have it
first we have to define what the concept
is and he didn't define it that your
rope hypothesis is conceptual no it's
physical rope is physical not conceptual
but you have to define these words in
order to be able to use them
consistently in a conversation he hasn't
done that so we don't know what he's
talking about
okay what is infinite well infinitely
the word used by idiots okay idiots use
the word infinite um it means uh i don't
want to answer the question that's what
infinite means
all objects are finite adjective
infinite can only be used in the context
of objects uh i i'm sorry adjective
definite right infinite you can't use
the word infinite object because there
is no such thing as a contradiction in
terms object is a
is something that has shape it's finite
and therefore all objects are finite
there's nothing infinite now counting is
not finite or infinite counting is
incessant or eternal or whatever you use
an ad adverb to qualify verbs okay
incessant is not an adjective only in
ordinary speech in physics incessant uh
is an adjective it's it can only qualify
a verb a verb it cannot qualify an
object you cannot say the table is
incessant unless you're talking about
the motion of the table okay so again
only for verbs
counting atoms that's mathematics and
the electromagnetic ropes
superimpose so you can put as many ropes
as you want all one on top of the other
no problem okay
and the question there is always you
know why don't you ask this question in
quantum mechanics quantum mechanics
tells you that particles superimpose
why don't you take the question up with
them okay because uh
apparently it's allowed in quantum but
you don't want it allowed in the rope
model
and then the ropes are invisible and
intangible since they don't have the
ability to touch there's no problem in
one rope super imposing upon another
or crossing another so they don't see or
touch you can't see or touch the rope so
there's no tangibility or visibility
between rope and you you and rope okay
just connection
okay uh faucets a hypothesis is an
assumption correct you are postulating
entities phenomenon phenomena properties
relations okay yeah essentially
we say that our hypothesis is the
objects the definitions and the initial
scene or statement of the facts which is
essentially what he put though in in
those words there but then he says
special relativity versus learns ether
theory theory those are not theories
those are descriptions
different entities and mechanisms are
proposed in uh both theories again not
theories
and then he does say later it says
despite these differences they use the
exact same models to
describe you got it all they are is
descriptions descriptions are not
theories
explanations are theories and
explanations have nothing at all to do
with descriptions
okay and so he says a collection of
theories models hypotheses that cannot
be compared against potential
conflicting observations is rather
useless
you have
similar falsifiable models but different
theories about the mechanisms in
question
and again all these people think it's
about
observing and falsifying
those terms are unscientific never use
them again at least in this channel okay
you're just making a fool of yourself
and what an idiot you got big ideas
so yeah what can i say
okay another fellow says gravity is a
centripetal force and he mentions so
chandrasekhar okay and um
i went there and i looked at his paper
and says the earth's gravity can be
viewed as the centripetal force
resulting from what coupling of its
rotational and orbital motions
that's not an explanation okay
and he says these motions were
presumably set in
uh trained in the early universe
the universe had no beginning there was
no early universe the universe has
always been late okay it's always been
there okay so we have the early universe
and we have no explanation for gravity
but these people say oh but it's a
centripetal centripetal force
what is he said
what is that
that's nonsense that's what it's called
we need a mechanism why is it a
centripetal force what causes it to be a
centripetal force that's the question
we're seeking for 2 500 years now not a
single mathematician on earth can answer
the question
and the last question here we say
everyone is wrong about force equals
mass times acceleration it isn't
newton's it's oilers
okay he's uh i i kind of agree newton
got a lot of credit for a lot of stuff
that he didn't do okay
and part of that was because it was a
big debate
in the uh
uh 16th century
even pouring into the early 17th century
especially between the uh newton on one
hand and uh
several people
you know on the on the on the continent
of the european continent
and
they were fighting for different
things that each one claimed to have
discovered invented or whatever and i
think when you look at
principia you don't find a lot of stuff
that he's being being credited for and
among those the three
laws of motion those are not newtons
okay
rene descartes and uh
galileo already were aware of you know
those laws
of motion not all of them not force
equals mass times acceleration then
number two but the first and the third
you know those
those were already around
you know so newton did not discover
those but he's credited and he's given
the three laws of motion of newton and a
lot has to do with
people who stood up for him in england
and fought these
uh these debates
between uh you know the continent and
england
and uh made him famous beyond uh
his own credits someone who hated his
guts because
uh said he plagiarized him several times
was robert hook when robert hook died
newton hated him so much that he
destroyed everything that robert hook
had left
at the um
is it the royal society and so we don't
even have a picture of robert hook today
because newton
in his
anger destroyed it